yeah we want to show you the big picture
because it is a big picture in 2019 to
2020 that is the best year for uh the
most recent records most reliable
pre-pandemic there are a total of nearly
000 calls about missing people uh in the
course of the year that's nearly a
thousand every day now many of those
calls the reports will be about the same
individual so the total number of
missing individuals recorded by the
police in England and Wales was a
hundred and fifty five thousand that
year and we know quite a lot about the
type of people who go missing adults
make up the biggest share here compared
to children but actually children are
overrepresented because they're a
smaller share of the general population
we can also break it down in terms of
gender significantly more men go missing
than women and we can break it down by
ethnicity here you can see how that
works the majority uh being white there
but uh black people are overrepresented
here again in terms of their share of
their population now Richard okorge went
missing in March 2021 he was found dead
two weeks later and an investigation
afterwards found that the police did not
take the case seriously enough we spoke
to Rich's mother evidence about that
your answers your worry your child is
not with you that's my baby
and I was told that if you can't find
your son how do you expect the police
officers to find your child for you I
was devastated that's the last thing
that a parent wants to hear when you're
looking for your only child Richard was
my only child race does play a major
part of it
you know your background plays major
parts especially if you're also
single parents as well
some of the most famous missing persons
case remain unsolved Lord Lucan vanished
in 1979 what nearly 17 000 more than 70
000 days he's never been found nor has
Madeleine McCann who disappeared in 2007
but those are the exceptions the
majority of people are found fairly
quickly 43 percent are found within the
first eight hours of an instant those
numbers get smaller the more you go on
two to seven days 11.6 7 to 27 days
where we are with Nicola bully it's only
3.6 and more than a month just 1.2
percent still missing the vast majority
of cases have a positive outcome when it
comes to children and adults
disappearing 96.8 percent of children uh
reappear without having suffered any
harm 89.5 of adults and there are
reasons why people go missing these are
the main ones here it's relationships
mental health drugs or alcohol
unaccompanied juveniles and then there
are lots of other reasons violent
reasons are there as well lot smaller
sexual exploitation you can see how much
they make up here sexual exploitation
was 2.7 gang-related 1.7 and domestic
abuse 1.3 but those aren't very much the
minority as you can see here and sadly
some cases do end internally in 2019 to
2020 there were 955 fatal outcomes